it's like the worst nightmare for a tide
head ever like any prop it's so bad and
we had they had scrums 5 me out from
from our Tri line and the first the
first one they pretty much almost got a
pen try but they managed to like I think
they knocked it on and then they reset
had another one I went down straight
away in the second one cuz I was just
under so much pressure and then got
penalty again and then the third one
white Crocker got under me and he lifted
me off the ground and as I was up in the
air he goes take your medicine boy and I
was like oh please sir please and he
just like lifted me up and then pushed
us over for a penalty try and I was just
like another one of those games where I
felt like this big and I came off the
pitch just being like Oh my God I think
I want to retire I felt so embarrassed
and he just like looked at me and said
take your medicine boy and I looked at
their front row and I was like all of
them had like a 100 All Blacks caps and
I'm just a little kid who's just like
played like five Super ugy Games getting
absolutely wrecked uh that was yeah I'll
never forget him telling me